kidnapper rapist murderer now we can add
flasher to the list of Wayne cousins
crimes already he will never leave
prison but today he was sentenced to yet
more time
for the offense against a count two on
indictment number T
2022-0638 the sentence is one of 19
months imprisonment
the court was played CCTV footage of
cousin's car after one incident his
number plate clearly visible information
that police had for three days before he
killed Sarah everard
the fact that no police came to find him
or his black car to question him about
these incidents can only have served to
confirm and strengthen in the
defendant's mind a dangerous belief in
his invincibility
could police have stopped him an
independent inquiry will seek to answer
such questions
now that Wayne cousins legal proceedings
have ended the police Watchdog the iopc
has been able to release the full
details of a WhatsApp group that was
fined on his phone after his arrest in
it cousins and six other serving
metropolitan police officers exchange
racist sexist and homophobic messages
most of which are too extreme to even
broadcast a warning that some viewers
may find even what we can show you to be
highly offensive
in February 2019 cousins joked with one
of his colleagues Matthew Forster
remember Foster it's got to be
consensual Forster replied they've only
got to say yes once
in June the same Year cousins and
officers Joel borders and Jonathan
cobbin shared racist descriptions of
areas of London like a Dulux color code
said Cobham all shades of Braun replied
borders
in July PC Gary Bailey asked how to
groom hot young foreign girls
on another occasion the officers
discussed consent and when a woman says
no during sex that counts as rape
even if you pretend you didn't hear it
asks borders
in a further exchange border said giving
a woman a black eye usually makes her
see things your way
all the officers involved have been
dismissed last year two of them borders
and cobbin were sentenced to 12 weeks in
prison
I asked the man I responsible for
standards in the Met police for his
reaction are we doing lots of things now
to root out those who are sexist
misogynistic racist we absolutely are
we have a long way to go we've already
taken tremendous steps to do much much
more around driving up standards and
rooting out those who should not be in
this organization
we and cousins has had his day in court
as for the Met police and their response
the jury is still out Matthew Thompson
Sky News